filip bump is with the washington post
he's here to discuss those debates and
much more so two debates right because
there are so many what the main issue
here is gonna be what is it the
front-runner which is Biden right now is
it an issue is it the president's I
think it depends on the candidate right
I mean this is gonna be the first time
these Democratic candidates have a
built-in audience right I mean you know
we all sit here and talk about this a
lot a lot of Americans haven't been
paying attention this will be their
first chance to really hear from the
candidates directly and the cameras are
gonna be going for different things some
of them going to be targeting bi and try
and take him out a lot of they're gonna
be trying to show hey I can beat Trump -
because electability is a big issue here
you have this this this group of Sanders
and Warren and Buddha judge we're going
to be fighting over the liberal vote
trying to establish their bona fides
there so a lot of them are doing a lot
of different things but this is a time
when America's tuning in so they're
gonna be focused on that what are the
most important things they can do though
to separate themselves from that pack
well it's this is really not a great way
to pick a president because one of the
things are gonna be doing is trying to
get that viral video right I mean I know
this is a new era if you look in the
2016 race the Republicans had a number
of candidates as well Carly Fiorina
really stood out during that what they
called the undercard debate she had a
great performance had a couple really
punchy moments there and she actually
boosted in the polls now was she you
know did that end up helping her over
the long term not particularly but she
did what it took to get people's
attention and that's what a lot of these
people gonna be buying this day and
early on Italy exactly I want to turn
things down to Iran attentions very high
right now with what happened last week
or this past week with the president
moving forward to strike then retreating
but how will this impact him politically
well I mean did the safest default
answer is that it probably won't affect
him politically I mean that's sort of
the default answer I've had for four
years now I think that had he actually
done the strike had a tensions escalated
with Iran and had there been a shooting
conflict with Iran that could have been
hugely problematic for him down the road
I'm not sure that his not doing that is
really going to affect things a whole is
there an issue with use of force here
though I mean between the executive and
the legislative branch I mean there is
but there has been for years I mean this
is something that's been basically you
know probably preceding the 2001 AUMF
this authorization for the use of
military force this has been a tension
for a long time I think that Trump has
had less of that tension simply because
for the past decade or so it hasn't been
much of an issue president raised 24
million
in the first 24 hours after announcing
his re-election campaign which Democrats
are in the best position when it comes
to fundraising right now well I think
Biden certainly is I mean Biden is a
frontrunner he's got the name appeal
he's got all these various things which
are gonna bring in money I mean I will
say about that that one of the lessons
we learned from 2016 from Trump himself
is that having a big nest egg doesn't
necessarily mean that you're in great
position also in 2016 we saw in the
second quarter of 2015 the equivalent to
now that Hillary Clinton raised almost
as much as the entire Republican field
so we'll have to see how the Democrats
do and once the Democrats have a solo
nominee how much money that person can
raise against Trump I think will be a
more important metric all right they'll
bump we thank you